The pandemic has certainly increased
violence against people with disabilities
because everyone was locked
in their house.
And in these four walls,
very difficult situations took place,
which has been talked about
and noted in Poland.
In addition, people with disabilities
are a group more exposed to Covid-19,
which has had a great impact
on their situation,
on their ability to create,
because being at home
doesn't help in creating.
Myself, being locked in my apartment,
my motivation dropped automatically
and I started to focus on my health.
The fact that it is the most important thing.
And I think that many people
with disabilities
seem to have left
their careers behind
because their health situation
was more important.
Maybe emotionally what I felt
was to be even more fragile
as a disabled artist in general
because sometimes I feel a bit insecure
and I think my insecurity comes from there.
That affected me a lot.
The contact with the people,
all the communications,
all that has to do with culture,
to learn some things...
I've noticed, since I don't have to travel,
it kind of reduced stress for me
like living in Berlin,
getting along,
finding things,
having to take the subway every day,
that reduced so much stress.
I will speak from my experience
as a deaf person,
Covid-19 gave me
the opportunity to face
which body I have.
For example, when people are talking
about something
and everybody has their masks on
and I'm like:
"Guys, would you like to share?"
The world is going faster than you
and it doesn't wait for you
and I'm not asking the world
to wait for me,
I'm just asking you to do
this simple movement.
Covid-19 took off our bodies from the society,
not just mine but even yours,
even able bodies,
everybody's bodies were taken off
the society
because we were at home,
locked down, etc.
It was a moment in which I really
understood my body,
this part of my body,
and without that pride coming from
telling people I'm deaf
I don't know which kind of art
I would have done.